رئيسه وزراء فنلندا سان مارن بتقوم بزياره
الى نيوزيلندا هي الاولى لرئيس وزراء
فلندي الى نيوزيلندا خلال الزياره التقطع
طبعا بنظيرتها النيوزيلنديه جستنداد
وبعد اللقاء عقدوا كمان مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
يعني كلها ترى اللي بيحكي لكم عنه امور
طبيعيه بيعملوها قاده سدوا العاده طبيعي
جدا يعني لكن خلال المؤتمر الصحفي في واحد
صحفي سال سؤال ما عجب الرئيس تين ورد عليه
على السريع والصراحه السؤال يعني ما عجبنا
حتى احنا كمان
يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
حول العالم
لانه هذا طبي يحمل الكثير من التمييز ضد
المراه يعني كانه بيقول لهم انتم مجتمعين
بس لانكم ستات زي بعض واعماركم قريبه من
بعض لانه ما لهم عمرها
372 يعني كانهم يعني انه صحتين وتوعد على
عشاء وبصراحه شكرا للرئيستين الحكومه انهم
ردوا عليه ويشوفوا غليلنا وما خلوا
الموضوع يعدي وكانها جمله عاديه يعني
يعني ربي بوب
سي مول
الغموض هم يبقى سؤال انه الامتحان عالي يا
جماعه من التمييزات هذا هل المراه خلاص
بحكومه حياتها كلها لانها تفضل تعاني من
التمييز هذا والنظره هذه يعني حتى رئيسات
حكومات وصلوا لمنصبهم بالانتخاب وترقصوا
احزابهم كمان وما خلصوا من هذا الموضوع
خلونا نتكلم اكثر مع ضيفنا من القاهره
الدكتور سعيد صادق استاذ علم الاجتماع
السياسي اهلا فيك معانا دكتور سعيد يعني
صراحه السؤال اللي طرحته رئيسه وزراء
نيوزيلندا صحيح انه هل لو كانوا هم الرجال
كانوا سالوا هذا السؤال
انا افتكرت حي اسالهم انت جايه من فنلندا
لنيوزيلندا عشان بلاك فرايدي نعمل شوبنج
لفساتين ولا حاجه
مضحكه جدا الشيء المضحك الشيء المضحك اولا
نيوزيلندا اول دوله في العالم
بتسمح بالتصويت للمراه
1893 اول دوله في العام تسمح بالتصوير
الثانيه في العالم كانت همم في اوروبا او
الاولى في اوروبا كانت في اللاندا
1906 سمعت للمراه بالتسويق وانها تترشح
وكان اول امراه تدخل القلمانات في العالم
كانت في فنلندا فطبعا الاثنين دول دولتين
دول نيوزيلندا وفيرندا بيتفخوا دائما انهم
كانوا اوائل الدول في العالم في همم
الحقوق اللي تم اعطائها للنساء وحتى في كل
التصنيفات الدوليه بنج لندن ونيوزيلندا من
الاوائل فطبعا السؤال اللي اتقال دوت يديك
انطباعي يا اما الشخص ده لا هو من
نيوزلندا ولا هو من فنلندا من بلد ثانيه
وبيفتقد انها دي حاجه يعني غريبه الغريب
في الموضوع ايه ان المؤسسات السياسيه لما
طلعت في العالم كانت مؤسسات ذكوريه كانت
دائما في تحيز على الرجاله الدستور
الامريكي اللي اتعمل
1,789 كان لم يذكر ان المراه له حق تصوت
ولا تنزل في في اي انتخابات ولا حاجه
ونضله المراه الامريكيه لحد ما اخذت حقا
انها تنزل تترشح
1920 والاول مره يبقى عندك نائبه دلوقت
يعني انت همم امريكا حتى يعني
بالنسبه لفلان ده ونيوزيلندا همم بريطانيا
في تاريخها كله اكثر من 10 قرون ما
جاءلهاش غير ثمان ملكات فطبعا عندنا تحيز
في المؤسسات السياسيه الثقافه السياسيه ضد
المراه
الدكتور سعيد انه خلص نحنا بارزين في
مجالاتنا وفي كثير من المجالات لمثل مجتمع
هيفضل يتعامل معنا على نظريه انه يعني هذي
جايه هنا بالصدفه معانا هي في الاساس كان
لازم تكون حبيبتي في المطبخ
طبعا احنا عندنا في العالم حاليا يمكن 26
نقع ماسكه سلطه تنفيذيه همم لكن اللي
بيحصل طبعا همم الناس لسه مش متعوده في
بعض حتى عن هذه الدول يعني متقدمه
وتاريخها طويله اللي احنا قلنا حتى همم في
اللاند مثلا سنه 90 كان عندها اول وزير
الدفاع في العالم باذن الله
نعودهم لازم نقعد عندكم في البيت يا دكتور
سعيد عشان تقتنعوا ههه
واحنا شوفنا كلهم في منتهى الكفاءه يعني
الكفاءه اللي عملتها السيدات احنا اولا
ليه السيدات دخلت في السياسه اصلا هم
دخلوا ليه هم لما لقوا ان الرجاله مش
عارفين يعملوا اداره للميزانيه ولا
السياسات العامه المراه طول الوقت بتشتغل
في التعليم في
تغذيه البيت في الصحه بتاعت البيت فهي
حاسه انها فاهمه اكثر من الرجاله اللي
قاعدين يعملوا قرارات وكلها خاطئه وبتعمل
مشاكل فبتعد تطلب انها تنزل نقولها لا ما
تنزليش لانك انت امراه ابتدت تناضل وكان
بيتم قتلهم لما كانوا بيتقالوا بحقهم انهم
ياخذوا حق التصويت فطبعا المراه ادخلها
مهم جدا للسياحه حتى كمان
بالضبط وكمان لانه المساله مساله كفاءه
يعني بس خليني اقول لك بدي اقرا لك عنوان
الزملاء في صحيفه الشرق الاوسط كل التحيه
لهم بس حاطين عنوان انه رئيستا وزراء
نيوزيلندا وفنلندا تحرجان صحفيا بسبب سؤال
عن سنهما فهم شايفين ان هم اللي احرجوا
الصحفي تعتقد اللي كتب العنوان هذا رجل
همم لا اعتقد او ممكن حد مؤمن
بالنساويه بالمساواه فممكن يكون رجل
مستنيين
وكانه مش الصحفي كانت غلطه طول النهار
بتاريخ نيوزيلندا وتاريخ في اللاندا لانه
لو كان همم التاريخ هيقف ان دول اوائل
الدول في العالم في الموضوع حق التصويت
وحق الترشيح في الانتخابات
مهمه في العمليه السياسيه
شكرا لك